thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video find out more later on hey 42 here
if you visit milton cemetery in
portsmouth england
you'll find a grave of a man named
alexander wilson
you'll know it's his because the
gravestone will read
he loved not wisely but too well
these words from shakespeare's othello
were chosen by wilson's children
and they seem to describe a bloke with
poor judgment
but a generous heart and i have to say
it was a rather fitting quote
because alexander wilson certainly had
plenty of love to give
by the time he died he'd worked his way
through four different wives with whom
he'd produced seven children but what
that gravestone in portsmouth won't tell
you is that wilson had all four of those
wives at the same time
and that somehow none of them knew about
each other until after he died
this then is the story of a man who
played many roles
he was a soldier and very probably a
british spy
he was a best-selling novelist he was
also a committed family man
so committed in fact that he had four
families in four different lives that he
lived completely separately from one
another
it's the story of how he managed to get
away with a lifetime of deception until
he died at the age of 69
and of how the house of cards he'd so
carefully built came tumbling down
but
that's the end of our tale
let's start
at the beginning
if you love travelling then you'll love
the fastest and easiest vpn surf shark
did you know surf shock helps you to
avoid price discrimination based on your
location so you can actually save money
on plane tickets and car rentals whilst
traveling
and surfshock runs on any device
anywhere and it's packed full of
features such as industry leading
uncrackable encryption ip and dns leak
protection an internet kill switch of
your vpn drops out and 24 7 customer
support basically by using surfshark you
can stay anonymous and secure online but
personally i use surfshark to watch
netflix content from other countries
such as the us that's usually blocked
here in the uk it's really easy all i
have to do is switch my location
settings and there i have it access to
all my favorite programs surfshark
maintains a strict no logs policy and
their network of 3200 servers in over 65
countries runs completely on ram so they
couldn't log your data even if they
wanted to by using the code 42 you'll
benefit from an 83 discount plus three
extra months for free
all you have to do is click the special
link in the description below don't miss
out
alexander wilson was born in dover
england on the 24th of october 1893. his
father was a korean military man so
alexander and his family followed him to
postings in far-flung corners of the
british empire like mauritius ceylon
hong kong and singapore
young alexander had an excellent
education at catholic schools in hong
kong and plymouth
though he was obviously absent the day
they taught the ten commandments or
maybe he was just out of the room when
the teacher got to thou shalt not commit
adultery
at the age of 21 wilson enlisted with
the royal naval air service to serve in
world war one
but he was honorably discharged in 1917
thanks to disabling injuries from
shrapnel
it was around this time that he married
his first wife gladys kelloway who he
would go on to have three children with
adrian dennis and daphne
after being recognized for his bravery
in the war wilson tried to re-enlist
what he was denied on medical grounds
so
he joined the merchant's navy instead
but after a voyage from london to
vancouver he was arrested for theft and
sentenced to six months hard labour in
british columbia
in less than a year he'd gone from war
hero to thief one of the many
contradictions of wilson's life also not
the last time he would be accused of
having sticky fingers after doing his
time in canada wilson appeared to turn
over a new leaf and went on to manage a
touring theater company with gladys from
1920 to 1925.
he will go on to use his experience as
inspiration for his tale the magnificent
hobo published in 1935
the first of many autobiographical
events to resurface when wilson became a
professional author later in life
but even at this stage in his career the
man already had a knack for spinning
good yarn
in 1925 some creative writing on his cv
landed him a position as a professor of
english literature at the university of
punjab in modern-day pakistan so wilson
soon set sail for british india to take
up his new academic post
leaving his wife and children at the
bottom of the gangplank
but
he wouldn't be lonely for long
on that same voyage to the east the
soldier turned sailor turned convict
turned theater director turned english
professor
met dorothy phyllis wick a british
actress he would become his second wife
the pair married three years later in a
public ceremony at the cathedral of
lahore
that's a place by the way not the french
way of saying the prostitute
even though no official wedding
certificate has ever been located
whatever document did exist would have
been as empty and meaningless as
well
sex with lahore
because wilson was still legally married
to poor old gladys when he tied the knot
for the second time
during his time on the subcontinent
wilson was a busy man he published his
second book the devil's cocktail
learned urdu and persian and became
principal of islamia college
some biographers though believe wilson's
position was actually just a cover for
his real work as an informant and
recruiter for british intelligence
wilson's book for example was an
espionage thriller set in lahore
describing the struggle between british
and russian intelligence
it features an all-muslim college and
the character remarkably similar to
wilson's boss abdullah yusuf ali
as with everything else it's hard to
know where wilson's real life ended and
the stories began
after resigning from the college in 1931
wilson spent the next few years as the
editor of a local newspaper or at least
that's what he claimed it's also thought
that he spent a fair bit of time
traveling around asia and the middle
east during this period particularly in
ceylon palestine and arabia
what he was doing in those countries no
one knows for sure
but it's the kind of behavior
that would have made sense if wilson was
indeed a spy
the region was rather unsettled at the
time
pro-independence movement and political
mayhem meant there were plenty of
terrorist activities assassinations and
high-profile events to keep an
intelligence officer busy
in 1933 wife number two dorothy returned
to england to give birth to michael her
and wilson's first child
well
their first child together
little did dorothy know that her husband
was already a father three times over at
this point
wilson followed them to london soon
after but it wasn't long before he left
dorothy and baby michael to return to
wife number one gladys and their three
children who were now living in
southampton he stayed with them for 18
months before moving back in with
dorothy and michael
now if you're wondering how the hell
wilson explained all these long absences
to his wives and children
it seems they also believed he was
involved in espionage of some sort
a mysterious job you aren't allowed to
talk about that involves a lot of travel
is pretty much the ideal cover story for
anyone who fancies having a go at
polygamy
but while spying was a great excuse to
spend time with whichever wife he chose
it seems wilson's job was rather less
well-suited to paying the bills
providing for a family can be costly
providing for two is downright expensive
the income wilson made as an offer and
probable spy
wasn't bad but it wasn't enough to
support both of his families
simultaneously
after filing for bankruptcy he was
forced to relocate to yorkshire and he
took dorothy and michael with him it
probably wasn't the flat capped whippets
or fine pork pies but something didn't
quite work out for wilson in yorkshire
and he left shortly afterwards in 1941
saying a final farewell to his young son
michael
a year later at the tender age of nine
the poor boy would be told by an uncle
that his father had been killed at the
battle of el alamein in egypt
this was another fine pork pie
wilson was alive and well
but despite the cruel deceit
michael like the rest of his siblings
would always remember his father as a
loving figure
in retrospect it's obvious that wilson's
real reason for leaving yorkshire was
you guessed it another future mrs wilson
a woman by the name of allison mary
mckelvey
in 1939 wilson had started work as a
translator for mi6 where he took over a
department running surveillance on
foreign embassies in london
allison was almost 30 years younger than
wilson but he won her over all the same
partly with the help of some forged
divorce papers after allison's apartment
was rendered unlivable by a german
bombing grade the two lovebirds moved in
together and in 1941 the same year he
walked out on dorothy and michael in
yorkshire
alison mckelvey became mrs wilson the
third
as well as ink in his pen the prolific
author clearly had plenty of lead in his
pencil because two more sons followed
shortly after his latest wedding
gordon and nigel becoming wilson
children numbers five and six
according to redacted reports in 1942
wilson was fired from his job as a
translator for apparently exaggerating
the contents of intercepted phone calls
but for once it may have been wilson who
was on the receiving end of a cunning
deception
the person investigating his
translations was a man by the name of
alex keller
who was later found to have been working
for anthony blunt an infamous kgb mole
who'd infiltrated the british
intelligence service
some have suggested that blunt targeted
wilson in an attempt to tarnish the
reputation of mi6 british foreign
intelligence
[Music]
whatever the reason for wilson's
dismissal the british government was so
annoyed with his antics that they made
an effort to stop him from getting any
other kind of worthwhile employment
as a result his publishing career was
effectively over leaving him and his
family sorry families penniless but
wilson wasn't the type of man to let
something so insignificant as reality
get him down he told allison he was
being sent undercover and that all the
bad luck that seemed to have befallen
them the money troubles and job losses
was actually just part of his elaborate
cover story
if alison believed this then she must
have been especially convinced when
wilson was declared bankrupt for a
second time and jailed for petty theft
also for a second time
on his release wilson took a job at
hampstead cinema but soon found himself
behind bars once again for stealing he
claimed the whole event had been staged
so that he could keep tabs on fascist
groups in brixton prison
making him one of those incredibly rare
prisoners who claims to be innocent
from afar it seems wilson's life was
falling apart but he obviously managed
to retain his charm
in the 1950s he was trying out another
new career this time as a hospital
porter
when surprise surprise he met the woman
who would become his fourth and final
wife
a nurse called elizabeth hill
the pair tied the knot in 1955 and
wilson now 63 fathered yet another son
douglas he was born in the same year
wilson would later use a fictional job
at the foreign office as an excuse to
stay in london when elizabeth and
douglas moved to scotland in 1957
in reality he was working in the
slightly less glamorous role of a clerk
in a wallpaper factory still a free man
once more wilson took the opportunity to
move back in with mrs wilson number
three in case you're struggling to keep
up that was allison and their sons
gordon and nigel
this was wilson's final move and he
lived out his twilight years in ealing
west london on the 4th of april 1963 it
was ironically wilson's heart that
finally gave out
clearly exhausted from a lifetime well
four lifetimes of loving too well
remarkably wilson's multiple marriages
were only discovered after he died
sifting through his personal papers
alison wilson found out about gladys
wife number one and contacted her to
give her the news and tell her about
wilson's other family alison would never
find out about dorothy and elizabeth the
other two wives but those details
eventually surfaced in later years
wilson had managed to keep his lives so
thoroughly separate that some of his
children didn't even learn of each of
his existence for close to 50 years
after his death
in the end the story of wilson's life
was as full of complicated plots twists
and turns
as one of his spy novels and just like
in those novels the hero at the center
of the tale got away with it all
thanks for watching